the next random variable that we will
discuss is the binomial random variable
it is one that is already familiar to us
in most respects it is associated with
the experiment of taking a coin and
tossing it n times independently and
that each toss there is a probability P
of obtaining hands so the experiment is
completely specified in terms of two
parameters and the number of tosses and
P the probability of heads at each one
of the tosses we can represent this
experiment by the usual sequential tree
diagram and the leaves of the tree are
the possible outcomes of the experiment
so these are the elements of the sample
space and the typical outcome is a
sequence a particular sequence of heads
and tails that has length and in this
diagram here we took and to be equal to
3 we can now define a random variable
associated with this experiment our
random variable that we denote by
capital X is the number of heads that
are observed so for example if the
outcome happens to be this one tails
heads heads we have two heads that are
observed and the numerical value of our
random variable is equal to 2 in general
this random variable a binomial random
variable can be used to model any kind
of situation in which we have a fixed
number of independent trials and
identical trials and each trial can
result in success or failure and we have
a probability of success equal to some
given number T the number of successes
obtained in these trials is of course
random and it is modeled by a binomial
random variable we can now proceed and
calculate the PMF of this random
variable instead of calculating the
whole PMF let us look at just one
typical entry of the PMF let's look at
this entry which by definition is the
probability that our random variable
takes the value of
now the random variable taking the
numerical value of 2 this is an event
that can happen in three possible ways
that we can identify in the sample space
we can have two heads followed by a tail
we can have heads tail heads or we can
have tails heads heads the probability
of this outcome is P times P times 1
minus P so it's P squared times 1 minus
P and the other two outcomes also have
the same probability so the overall
probability is 3 times this which can
also be written this way 3 is the same
as 3 choose 2 it's the number of ways
that you can choose 2 heads where they
will be placed in a sequence of 3 slots
or 3 trials more generally we have the
familiar binomial formula so this is a
formula that you have already seen it's
the probability of obtaining K successes
in a sequence of n independent trials
the only thing that is new is that
instead of using the traditional
probability notation now we're using PMF
notation to get a feel for the binomial
PMF it is instructive to look at some
plots so suppose that we toss the coin
three times and that the coin tosses are
fair so that the probability of heads is
equal to 1/2 then we see that one head
or two heads are equally likely and they
are more likely than the outcome of 0 or
3 heads now if we change the number of
tosses and toss the coin 10 times then
we see that the most likely result is to
have 5 heads and then as we move away
from 5 in either direction the
probability of that particular result
becomes smaller and smaller now if we
toss the coin many times let's say a
hundred times the coin is still fair
then we see that
the number of heads that we're going to
get is most likely to be somewhere in
this range between let's say 35 and 65
these are values of the random variable
that have some noticeable or high
probabilities but anything below 30 or
anything above 70 is extremely unlikely
to occur we can generate similar plots
for unfair coins so suppose now that our
coin is biased and the probability of
heads is quite low equal to 0.2 in that
case the most likely result is that
we're going to see zero heads and then
they're smaller and smaller probability
of obtaining more heads on the other
hand if we toss the coin 10 times we
expect to see a few heads not a very
large number but some number of heads
between let's say 0 & 4 finally if we
toss the coin a hundred times and we
take the coin to be an extremely unfair
one what do we expect to see if we think
of probabilities as frequencies we
expect to see heads roughly 10% of the
time so given that n is 100 we expect to
see about 10 heads but when we say about
10 heads we do not mean exactly 10 heads
about 10 heads in this instance as this
plot tells us is any number more or less
in the range from 0 to 20 but anything
above 20 is extremely unlikely